welcome to this video playing snuba here
with black frequent opponent from
Germany I've played him number of times
with a very bad score mostly time losses
but let's see what happens he's playing
default Bishop f4 the London I'm going
for an Hedgehog side up which I very
often do against those openings it
promises to be quite ok long term for
black yeah yeah the normal white
strategy here is to do nothing just
shuffle and maybe try to win on time oh
now he's doing something 5 strange
okay I'm blocking blocking the queenside
going 45 um should i do if I've here I
can do it I can do that here now now
capturing would give me great control
over over the dark square so he will
very likely move the bishop yeah and
let's see maybe rook the Aten just try
to improve slightly I am controlling f5
maybe activate the bishop on age 6 or g7
okay i want them can I do something in
this position or do I only have
shuffling moves I want I want to put
some pressure on this night so maybe
move the Queen away are we here so that
i may be at some point threatened to
take on f3
we are taking on f3 and trying to we're
all so nice to see d4 d5 which would
give me the the square here on c5 of
course remove the knight on f6 mm-hmm
yeah if i move the knight on f6 you
might have 95 which it's not very very
nice i probably should retreat the Queen
from them from getting hit by 95 with
the temple it was not threatening
directly or anything but ok so white
after all decides to to do something I
am not quite sure what I mean what did
what is doing if I had take d4 and you
will go here maybe ok let's see I can
also take on f3 first and then take with
the night take on f3 takes on he takes
on f6 take 1 e 2
yeah it is working i can also just grab
here but ok let's let's take them yeah
I'm wonder nite nite see foyer might
give white give white play here he gets
play with 94 to a five hmm interesting
mmm yeah i wonder if i should take with
the pawn
yes might give me more play in the long
run I want to go Eve form possibly push
on age 60 k exchange their first
okay so we just have some trade cm and
he keeps he keeps the spawn on a five
yeah that came the the apron is always
always dangerous if when it is supported
by by the f3 bishop
that's what I haven't an extra point in
the center and ideas with bishop age six
okay time warning didn't really think
that this was so great but [ __ ] my chief
or maybe isn't this sir in the symbols
don't I don't know what his response now
is and not that he's losing or anything
but i thought this should should be
totally okay for me so i can take I can
take a for now okay I'm so yeah f7 on f7
could could be an issue so let's protect
it for the moment yeah he's up on time
and now we have the main scenario way
how is winning games against me just pin
just out of nothing positions and burn
on time
check
yeah this position is just nothing for
white absolutely nothing yeah no no I'm
starting to be better check yeah okay
equal it's equal Zack let's not get too
ahead I could have taken a small
yeah nine seconds stuff check
check check yeah this is why this time
control is so great check blood that's
on time yeah okay yep this is so not
really great am I mean black is always
totally okay there's nothing happening
ever but I just spend too much time here
white has this sort of activity against
F settlement there's nothing happening
and here here blackest here black is
better here I can just play f6 and so on
but okay I have 16 seconds it's just
it's just not very great if people can
play nonsense like g4 against you and
still win because you'll know on time
this is not happening with the decent
time control but okay it's it's no use
to to state that all the time I know but
it's still bad okay thanks for watching